You just made a very important observation. Some scripts don't modify the DOM or
the CSSOM. And really, they shouldn't block
rendering. And Analytics is a great example.
>> Yeah. I wish we had some way to tell the browser exactly that.
>> Actually, we can. One strategy would be to load the script after the page is
loaded. So when the browser fires the onload
event. And we could execute the script then.
>> All right, how would I do that?
>> The browser fires an on load event when the page is is finished loading.
And you can wait for that and then execute your script
then. Check the instructor notes for instructions on how to do that.
>> Okay, will do. Is there anything else?
>> Yeah, the on load technique is a good one
to have in your back pocket, but there's actually an even
simpler strategy that we could use. All we need is
an extra attribute on the script tag. Let me show you.
>> Cool.
>> I've pulled out our analytics code into a
separate file and added the async attribute to the
script tag. This attribute has two important properties. First,
it tells the browser that it does not have
to block DOM construction. When it encounters the script
side. As a result, the browser dispatches the script request,
and continues parsing the DOM. Second, the execution of
the script does not block on the CSS Object
Module. So, if the script is available before the
CSS Object Module is ready. It can still be executed
right there and then.
>> Oh wow, that's handy. So async basically means
that the script does not block the critical routing path.
>> Exactly. The browser will download and execute the script but
it won't block the parcer, and it won't block on CSS.
>> What about inline scripts? Can I put an async attribute on an inline script?
>> Unfortunately that wouldn't work. Inline scripts will always block on the
CSS Object Model. Well, with one exception. If you put your JavaScript
above your CSS, then it will execute without blocking on CSS.
To learn more about this pattern and async scripts, check out
the link in the instructor notes. Let's do a quick exercise
to see if you can spot the difference between these patterns.